It is time to play
"Can You Feel It?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Can you feel it? ♪
-But I am going to
need some help.
She stars in the giant new movie
"The Batman,"
in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.
Please welcome Zoe Kravitz!
♪♪
-♪ Can you feel it? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-I'm scared.
-I know.
Don't even look at that.
That's a standing O
for you, bud.
They love you.
-Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, Zoe Kravitz.
All right, Zoe, here's how --
here's how this works.
We're gonna have
a number of mystery objects
brought out in front of us.
And our job is to guess
what is -- each one is.
The catch is that we have
to figure out by touch alone.
Since you're our guest,
why don't you go first?
-Great.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's see
what your first object is.
You'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
All right.
Whenever you're ready.
-Hey, now, hey.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
Oh, God.
Okay.
Can I ask some questions?
-Yeah.
-Is it alive.
-No.
-Stop it.
You're --
You are scaring me.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's silly.
-Aah!
I'm so scared!
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
-It's nothing.
It's fake dog poop.
-Eww!
-All right, here we go.
-I really can't.
-Now, I am up here.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God.
Oh, no.
You'll be fine.
Right?
-I just want to
switch the boxes up!
-Who picks this?
This is crazy.
-No, this is all crazy.
[ Cheers ]
[ Screaming ]
Aah!
I hate this game!
I hate it!
I touched this!
Whatever it was.
I don't know what it is.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, don't say that to me.
-I'm sorry.
-Don't say that to me.
-No, you're fine, you're fine.
-Oof! It's like something --
-Oh, God.
Oh.
-Aah!
-I'm scared for you.
[ Screaming ]
-It's wet! It's wet!
It's so wet, it's disgusting!
[ Laughter ]
Ugh! It's so gross.
I'm gonna throw up.
I swear, I'm gonna throw up
and get sick.
It's cold, and it's wet,
and something licked me, maybe.
Is it a cat?
Aah!
I can't do it!
I'm freaking out right now!
Can I go over on this side?
-Yeah.
[ Screaming ]
-Something else licked me!
This is so weird!
I hate this game.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna touch it.
[ Screaming ]
I don't know what it is!
I can't do it!
What is it?!
[ Buzzer ]
-It's popsicles.
-What?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
It felt like something
was licking me.
was moving and licking me.
It was so gross.
-It's crazy what our minds do.
-Right?
Also, you didn't help,
either, going "Oh, no."
-I know, I'm sorry.
Isn't that the game?
-Yeah, it is.
Zoe, here you go.
-Okay.
-Good luck.
-Thanks.
Jimmy...
Ohh!
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'm brave.
I'm cool, and I'm brave.
-Right?
-And I'm cool.
-Yeah, you can do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aah!
I touched it.
What is it?
I have no -- what is it?
-No, just try it again,
try it again.
Oh, no!
-Stop it!
[ Laughter ]
A turtle?
-No. But not bad.
-Really?
-It's a honeycomb.
With a fake bee.
A honeycomb.
-Oh.
[ Cheers ]
That's not a turtle.
-No, it's not a turtle.
I didn't know how long
I still wanted to act.
How many more boxes do we have?
Because I'm freaking out.
All right.
[ Breathes deeply ]
-Oh, what is --
What is that?
[ Audience groaning ]
-I don't know what that is.
-Well, I know what that is,
and that's the sound
of everyone going, "Ugh."
[ Laughter ]
-It's the sound of us
not knowing what it is.
-All right.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know what that is,
but it --
Oh, I don't like it.
I don't like that.
♪♪
Ugh!
You're close!
You're close.
Aah! You're close!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Oh.
Ugh.
-Is that -- I have no idea.
Is that a turtle?
Is it a turtle?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughs ]
What if we keep guessing turtle?
-It's only turtles.
-Ohh!
-What is it?
-What is it?!
-What...is it?
[ Screaming ]
What is that?!
-What is it?!
What was that?!
-What is it?
-What is it?!
What is that?!
-What?
Why would I touch that?
-Is that a clam?
-Yes.
-Oh, my God darn it.
-Oh.
-Get it absolutely out of here.
All right.
Zoe, it's our last round.
Final round.
Now, for this one...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...we're both gonna get
the same box, okay?
We're both gonna
put our hands in, okay?
And then we'll
have to guess what it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter continues ]
-I love you, bud.
-I don't want to!
-I love you -- I know!
-I don't wanna!
I want to go this way.
-This way?
-Yeah.
[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
♪♪
Aah!
It moved! It moved!
-It's rubber.
-It moved, it moved!
-You -- it's rubber.
-Did I touch you?
-That was -- was that you?
-Did I touch your hand?
If we keep going...
♪♪
Aah!
-Oh, God!
-It's rubber!
It's rubber!
-No, it's -- it's a Batman mask.
-Oh. Oh!
It's moving!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my God.
-There's someone in there.
-Oh, my God,
there's a human being in there.
-Oh, my gosh.
-There's a human being.
-Do I know you?
-It's a grown man.
-I don't even know who you are.
Get out of here.
-No.
-My thanks to Zoe Kravitz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so sorry.
We're talking to Zoe
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.